coming up on 6 26 on your wednesday
morning we got a kind of an update on
that proposed bridge over the 95 in the
far northwest valley north of the
centennial bowl
there are bridges over the freeway here
at elkhorn and just north at durango but
not up ahead at grand teton we've talked
before about how if that's going to
happen it'll be a city of las vegas
project
here's part of a driving ukrainian
report from december of 2020. we got an
email from viewer patrick who wrote we
live just off osablanc and grand teton
six years ago we were told a bridge was
in the plans over the 95 to grand teton
on the east side of the freeway is this
ever going to happen and the city's
public works department says the bridge
will take 18 months to build and may be
completed in late 2022 or early 2023 all
right well here we are in 2022 almost a
year over a year later while the city of
las vegas says they do have the funding
to build the bridge they're now hopeful
that both the nevada department of
transportation and the federal highway
administration will sign off on required
environmental studies in june that would
allow them to put the project out for a
bit so you tack on another 18 months
from whenever a contractor's on board
you're looking at at least late 2023 now
or early 2024 for a grand teton bridge
over the 95. buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com